I remember when I first heard that I was
nominated for an Oscar it was just
mind-blowing I mean I really didn't get
into his career with the idea that I
would get an Oscar I just really wanted
to do whatever I can to create the
Fantastic imagery that supported the
story it really kind of took me to like
Oz I felt like I was in fantasy land it
was it was very surreal and that night
in the theater told myself okay just
listen for your name if you hear your
name then stand up and the Oscar goes to
and when they got to the category I
heard nothing Ken Ron
SM the Tom J for Death
Becomes well everybody else stood up and
I just stood up and I remember I just
started walking with them and then it
was only a little bit later on I
realized wow we we got nominated we won
when I was up on stage it was completely
dream like I mean this is kind of the
Pinnacle of our career in terms of you
know being awarded an Academy Award so I
was very thankful for that and the next
day when I returned to work it was like
okay great job Doug but get back to work
and it was only about a week after my
parents were working overseas and they
sent me articles uh headlines from
Taiwan I was born in Taiwan and it was
really amazing that um to think that my
award actually was influencing a whole
generation of other kids perhaps and
that really meant something more
powerful to me than me winning something
that's what was really special for me it
was just the profound effect it wasn't
me getting the award it was how it
affected others I would like to thank
Patty Blau Debbie Denice um the ilm
Department the model shop my mom and dad
and Liz Hanks and all my wonderful
[Applause]
friends